تواصل انقر تصعيد عمليتها العسكريه شمال
سوريا بهدف اقامه حزام امنيه من الغرب الى
الشرق على طول الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا
لابقاء الحدود امنه كما تقول وفي التفاصيل
الميداليه استهدفت الضربات الجويه التركيه
مطار العسكري
وقرى بريف حلب الشمالي وفقه طبعا المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان الذي اكد ان السلاح
الجوي التركي يواجهه ضربات جويه مكثفه عبر
الطيران الحربي والطائرات المسيره
للمقاتلين الاكراد ومن الارض المدفعيه
التركيه تطلق القذائف بشكل مكثف وعنيف على
المقاتلين الاكراد في شمال سوريا واصيبه
هنا نحو مئه وخمسه وعشرين شخصا خلال خمسه
ايام من القارات الجويه التركيه على
المناطق الكرديه بشمال سوريا وزاره الدفاع
التركيه اعلنت مقتل اثنين وعشرين مسلحه من
حزب العمال الكردستاني مالي سوريا والعراق
خلال اليومين الاخيرين في ظل استمرار
التحديدات التركيه هذا هو اعلنت قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد وقف عملياتها ضد
تنظيم داعش مشدده على انها ستتصدى لاي عمل
بري تركي ماذا فعل الى دخول تعزيزات
عسكريه ضخمه لقوات التحالف الدولي في
مناطق شمال وشرق سوريا قادمه من اقليم
كردستان العراق المشهد في شمال سوريا
عارضته واشنطن بشده حيث طالبت انقره في
وقفه عملياتها العسكريه وروسيا بدورها
اعربت عن امالها بوقف التصعيد التركي
[موسيقى]